the art of bill cosby mccarthy called
trump
what did trump said tristan threatens
death to lamar on instagram hashtag
kardashian
these are all topic ideas for this
particular channel that an ai robot says
i should make i would have great success
making any of those videos
unfortunately most of those titles are
complete nonsense
and to the except they're not nonsense
i'm not going to be making any of those
videos that being said
i think it's worthwhile going through
some of these titles because
hey they're hilarious and b some of them
actually aren't that bad for background
purposes i subscribe to a youtube tool
called vid
iq it's pretty good i like it and it
just has a new feature
and this is not sponsored where they
come up with ideas for my channel using
ai
technology now my friend tom scott did a
whole video about using the ai
technology gbt3 to
come up with topic ideas for his channel
and he even did a follow-up
where he used that technology with a
bunch of other youtubers he didn't ask
me to be
in that video and i'm definitely not
upset about that
but now that i think i have access to
probably the same
technology let's use it on the channel
and take a look at the videos that
the ai robots say i should make now i'm
not going to be making any of these
videos so if you
are a youtube lawyer who is looking for
ideas
please take these ideas i'd love to see
them i'm looking at you richard hogue
eve cornwell and attorney tom please use
any of these ideas i think it'd be
hilarious so let me explain why i'm not
going to make any of these videos
the first topic is donald trump and the
gop
i mean that one's just too obvious right
i mean donald trump is the gop and
frankly
on this channel i try not to do overtly
political content unless there is some
legal angle to it so
i i don't think there's a legal angle
there
president trump versus kamala harris uh
that'd be interesting i think everyone
would like to see that cage match
but there's no real legal issue there
all of the talk of the 25th amendment is
now over so i don't think there's any
reason for legal eagle to do
a president trump versus kamala harris
video
and then we have afghanistan comma trump
versus social media comma
shaqiri richardson ah man
that could be a really interesting video
putting
afghanistan and trump on one side and
social media and shakiri richardson on
the other if you don't know
shakira richardson is the female us
athlete she's a runner she was i think
disqualified from the olympics because
she tested positive for marijuana ah boy
i i could probably come up with some
legal angle i mean obviously
in this tag team match you have trump
versus social media so it's all about
section 230 but then afghanistan and
shakiri richardson
i don't see any reason why they would be
at odds with each other so this one
probably doesn't work
then we have a frankly a fantastic idea
for a video
it has only one problem let's see if you
can figure out what that is and the
topic idea is
bill cosby gets the chair
the problem is uh there's no universe in
which
bill cosby is going to get the chair he
was released from prison um
you know how i would do here's if i did
it here's how i would do it i would do
an alternate universe where i would
explain how all of the laws
would need to be different in order for
bill cosby to actually get the chair
that's how i would do that video that
could be really interesting
yeah i'll have to think about that one
then we have actually another great idea
for a video part two
britney spears documentary this is great
because i don't even have to make part
one i just go straight to part two
part one's gonna be boring anyway it's
really part two of the britney spears
documentary that it really gets good
so that's a great idea i just don't
really have time
to do an entire documentary about
britney spears but i do like the idea of
just completely skipping over part one
and going straight to part two
donald trump racist in chief
i mean there's no there's no legal video
there it's also a little too on the nose
i think
and like it or not simply saying racist
things
isn't illegal i mean i guess you could
you could do a survey of the laws that
donald trump wanted to pass or the
executive orders that he passed and you
could make a judgment call on that but
yeah
frankly i think we're all a little tired
of talking about the former guy at this
point
so then we have shakiri richardson
denied participation in the olympics and
shacary richardson is out of the
olympics both great topics
no real legal issue there if the
olympic committee wants to make a law
about precluding people who have tested
positive for marijuana from
participating in the olympics they can
make that
rule it's not an american law nothing
really for for me to talk about there
yes marijuana laws in general are stupid
that's not my
perspective as a lawyer that's just my
perspective as a human being with a
heart which
often is at odds with my perspective as
a lawyer who
you know is not allowed professionally
to have a heart but
i don't think there's really anything
there for for me to talk about on this
channel at least
someone should make that video though
bill cosby needs to be in jail rant
video
nah you know frankly i see the reasons
why bill cosby
is not in jail anymore there are
reasonable fifth amendment arguments for
why
he was let out of jail a lot of people
disagree with me
my friends over at opening arguments
think that bill cosby should be in jail
and if they had more of uh presence on
youtube they could totally make that
bill cosby should be in jail rant video
they absolutely should but they're happy
just to do a podcast
so you know take that andrew
and then we have a video that i kind of
already did britney spears speaks out in
court
asks to end conservatorship i did an
entire video on the britney spears
conservatorship i will probably do
another video
when the conservatorship issue reaches
ahead in fact there was a
big news article that she was able to
finally hire her own
attorney of her choice that's big news
and this whole saga is pretty
interesting from a legal perspective
i think my title is better than theirs
but reasonable minds can differ and
reasonable robots can differ too
oh well this one i'd have a hard time
making
bill cosby is innocent part two now
putting aside
that i'd have to make a part one on that
just because bill cosby was
released from jail does not by any means
make him innocent in any way whatsoever
in fact the overwhelming
uh evidence is that he was guilty of the
crimes at issue
but look the criminal justice system is
about protecting our rights as much as
it is
punishing the people who offend and
commit these crimes
i'm not gonna make that video about uh
bill cosby being innocent i'm sure there
are some other people out there that
could
it's not for me and
speaking of which donald trump is not
racist
again you know this channel is about
presenting
both sides and presenting facts as facts
when they're
sort of objectively correct um that
being said
i'd have a hard time making that
argument i'd uh i'm not saying i can't
i'm not saying it's impossible i'm just
not sure that i want to spend a whole
lot of time and effort
trying to make that argument
so here's an interesting one nyc
journalists arrested for filming
the arrest of protesters uh i can't
remember the last time a new york city
journalist was arrested filming the
protesters uh
it definitely happened a bunch this
summer
uh it'll happen again um so maybe i'll
keep that in my back pocket for
the next time it happens because it's
gonna happen again
again with bill cosby bill cosby gives
his kids alcohol
i mean poor theo but uh yeah i i'm not
sure that there's much of a legal issue
there
and uh yeah i don't i don't
let's not let's not do that
and speaking of which the memes that
freed bill cosby uh i'm not sure
what exactly those memes are uh i
probably could find some fifth amendment
memes
and i could use those memes to explain
why bill cosby went free
that's a great idea for a video yeah i
don't think in general memes played a
big part in
the vacating of bill cosby's sentence
hashtag the group chat shakira
richardson bill cosby tabitha brown
versus wendy williams and rachel nichols
i i don't even know what to do with that
that doesn't make any sense
then this one comes out of left field
steven jackson defends rachel nichols
did he i don't even is that is that true
i'm not even sure to be honest i will
not be touching that one with a 10-foot
pole
and then one last bill cosby idea the
bill cosby fun game bill perenne
cosby released from prison i don't even
want to think about what the bill cosby
game would be i just know i don't want
to play
it and then finally we have
uh a topic that i will not be making on
this channel
talking about controversial trans topics
ah
yeah i suppose i could have my friend
harry bruis from hbomberguy come on the
channel
and we could have a discussion about the
legal implications of all of the
different things surrounding
those topics but i really don't think
the comment section is going to be
particularly civil in a video entitled
talking about controversial trans topics
i'm gonna have to workshop that one just
a little bit
yeah so maybe skynet isn't as close to
fruition as we thought and the ai
robot uprising is not right around the
corner but if robots do start invading
you'll need to call the authorities and
you can save money on that call by
switching to today's sponsor
ting mobile i personally switched to
ting mobile and saved literally hundreds
of dollars a month
and i'm not kidding why because of this
yes this is a real cell phone bill that
i got with my previous provider and it's
why i personally switch to ting
and ting mobile has three brand new
plans to make sure this never happens
again
all of ting's plans have unlimited talk
and text starting at just ten dollars
per month add data for as little as five
dollars per gigabyte
choose a set of data or get a full
unlimited plan for only 45 dollars a
month you can run as many ai simulations
as you want
though this video will show you that the
ai simulations are probably not worth
all that much
but switching plans is actually really
easy because you can keep your same
phone number and use pretty much any
phone
and the service is great too because
ting partners with several massive
networks
probably the very same one that you're
using right now but at a huge
discount they literally use the exact
same infrastructure now actually i can't
tell you which ones because
i always respect contracts and
non-disclosure agreements
but let's just say that my service
hasn't changed at all and if you're
around wi-fi all the time like you're
working from home you have the
flexibility to save hundreds of dollars
using
ting's flex plan like you always have or
now you just have the possibility of an
unlimited version as well so if you want
unlimited you can go absolutely crazy
and it's incredibly easy to transfer
service you just simply order a ting sim
card pop it in
and set it up no phone calls required
it's like magic but if you do want to
talk to ting you can call them up and
immediately
talk to a real human being or use chat
or discord you'll talk to a real human
not an ai robot with virtually no wait
times
so if you would like to give ting a try
legal eagles will get a 25
service credit that could cover two
months of service all you have to do is
just click on the link below and give it
a try or you can use your last bill to
compare just how much you would save
just click on that link below plus it
really helps out this channel and while
you're at it check out this playlist
with all of my legal meme reviews and
lawyer jokes
so remember click on this playlist or
i'll see you in court